-My first guest is one of the
biggest names in country music,
who just announced his
"Proud to be Right Here" tour,
which kicks off July 8th.
Please welcome Luke Bryan,
everybody!
Oh, great to see you, buddy!
That's what I'm talking about.
-What's up?
-It is great to see you, buddy.
Welcome back to the show.
Congrats on this,
by the way, here.
This is the deluxe version
of your album
"Born Here, Live Here,
Die Here," which is out now.
And soon, you're gonna be able
to perform these songs live,
because you just announced
you're going on tour.
-Then I'm gonna be able to put
the deluxe of the deluxe
of the deluxe out.
-Of course,
that's what we're all wait--
Exact-- Yeah.
Or just release
a whole new album, yeah.
The tour starts July 8th.
Tickets are available
this Friday.
What are you looking forward to
most about the tour?
-Well, my thing is I keep --
I keep thinking about that
emotion that I'm going to have
when the lights come on
and I come out onstage
for the first time
and I finally am back out there.
I mean, I think we're --
You know, when you're --
You've heard the term
kind of road dogs,
and I've kind of always been a
guy that loves to be on the road
and loves to be out there
with the fans and interacting.
And, you know, the main thing
is, I just think about
that moment
when, you know, I hit the stage,
and it's interesting.
I mean, I've even done some --
You know, I've done
a couple Zoom concerts,
and, I mean, I'm, like,
forgetting the words to my songs
quite a bit.
So I got to like -- I mean,
I'm going to have to
sit in my music room
and, like, go back
and listen to --
Like, I'm going to have to
do a little extra prep,
because I'm a little out of
practice on a lot of this stuff.
-A little rusty.
I will say that when we --
We're lucky enough that we have
58 people in our audience,
and they are as loud as --
[ Cheers and applause ]
They're as loud
as 10,000 people.
And coming out --
Coming out behind the stage
and just seeing and hearing the
applause, it's emotional, buddy.
It really is.
-Yeah, it sounds like a big,
ol', full room in there.
So, yeah, you got some --
You got some loud --
-That's exactly right.
This is New Yorkers, man.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Don't mess -- New Yorkers know
what's up, and they love you.
-No one can yell
like New Yorkers, right?
-No one in the world.
There's no spirit like this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I have to say,
because, obviously,
you couldn't be bigger and
more successful in your career,
and everything is going great,
and then you post
this Instagram post
that made me laugh really hard,
and you said --
Your quote was,
"I got to work harder."
It's a picture of you
on some television show,
but underneath you,
it says, "Blake Shelton."
[ Laughter ]
That's classic.
Come on! You worked this hard.
You have how many #1's?
You're like,
"You think I'm Blake Shelton?"
-That's former Sexiest Man Alive
right there on his couch.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's a good line.
Obviously, you must know Blake.
-Yeah, before I --
I think even before I --
Before I even posted it
on Instagram,
I sent -- I sent it to Blake,
and I'm like,
"I mean, my life is pretty much
over after this point."
[ Laughter ]
You know, Blake just
chooses to go gray.
You know, he just chooses to,
like, look like a silver fox.
You know, I mean,
I got a lot "Just for Men"
and hair products --
-Yes, exactly.
You take care of yourself.
-And I work hard on this.
-You work hard on this, exactly.
-And I can't even still -- I
still can't separate from Blake.
It's just a shame.
-[ Laughs ]
I want to talk about
"American Idol."
You're fantastic on it, bud.
And it's -- The whole crew is
great over there.
I know that you had to miss
the first live show
because of COVID, which must
have been scary for you.
But, also, what was it like
going through that
and also missing the shows?
-Well, that's the fortunate --
You know, like so many people
out there, it was --
Like, I was one of those
that, I mean, I was doing
as good as I could.
Like, I really had done
a great job
at, you know, masks
and all of that.
And then to have that happen,
it was a bummer,
and I was like, "Oh, gosh, this
is gonna be a media nightmare
and I'm going to
have to miss stuff."
But thankfully, you know,
thankfully got through,
just, I kind of --
Kind of quarantined myself off
in a part of the house.
And it was pretty easy --
You know, pretty easy to get
through as far as my symptoms.
But certainly glad
I'm back in the chair now.
I'm back rocking.
And I love -- Love the show
this year, love the talent.
I mean, you know, and even --
I mean, we get
a little redundant.
I mean, we keep saying, "Our
talent's better than last year,"
but, you know, we --
We -- We've had producers,
and we've had Seacrest,
who's been there since day one.
I mean, he's pretty shocked
and amazed at the talent,
and, you know, we feel like --
You know,
we did a lot of auditions
where the kids could
audition via Zoom
and via just their computer,
and we felt like
that brought a lot of talent
out of the woodworks,
so it's been a great year.
-You've been great
and very supportive.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Luke Bryan on
"American Idol."
Take a look at this.
-Let's just walk
and you sing it.
-Yeah, you know what?
-And we're just gonna walk it.
-We won't look at you.
-Ready. Come on.
-Yeah, ready?
-♪ I got a girl crush ♪
-Yes, you do.
-♪ Hate to admit it, but ♪
♪ I got a hard rush ♪
♪ It ain't slowin' down ♪
-Come on, now.
-Give me a little bit
more frosting.
-♪ I got a girl crush ♪
-There it is.
-The way you say crush
is magic.
-Okay.
-Crush.
-That's good!
-Whoo!
-Alright.
-Come on.
That's what you want to see.
Luke Bryan! "American Idol" airs
Sundays at 8:00 p.m. on ABC.